back time now for the fastest seven
first up who's actually in charge here
joe biden having to share his time
magazine person of the year cover
with kamala harris greg that's
interesting what do you think that's all
about
well number one this year there are so
many heroes uh the american people
probably should have been on the cover
because they're the ones who flatten the
curve
not these folks but you know what i like
about this cover
they only printed one and they just
showed it to joe
everybody else it's just kamala harris
dana dana kamala must be pretty happy
about that cover
i don't know she probably is going to
ask someone to photoshop
it you know turn it around so she could
have some time magazine she'll probably
she'll probably have it at some point um
i mean not a surprise
that they would decide on these two but
i think to greg's point there were lots
of different heroes this year especially
those front line workers that many of
them haven't had a day off and they work
20
hour days trying to save people in the
hospital so
i don't know what did they what did they
what did the chair do
really what did they do anyway sorry
judge who would you have given time
magazine person of the year to
well there anyone whether it's the front
line workers the doctors the people
working on the vaccine the companies
that got involved
but you know what this reminds me of
this reminds me of barack obama he
wasn't even in there a week and a half
and they decided to give him the nobel
peace prize when he hadn't done anything
and he sent more people to war
during the eight years he was there so i
mean it's an agenda it's it's the left
agenda
who cares about this yeah geraldo this
kind of lost its luster many many years
ago as the
magazine industry kind of took a turn
i'll say i don't know where you can even
buy
time magazine anymore but i will say
this about kamala harris remember
the the first african-american and that
high
office uh you know she her ascension
has been an inspiration to to millions
of
of young women particularly not solely
but uh young girls
you know not just specifically but
generally speaking and and i think that
for us
you know politics is one thing but you
know uh
history is is something else
all right is it facts first or fashion
first
a cnn anchor getting roasted for going
on camera wearing
a 380 dollar cashmere sweater with the
network's tagline on it
if only the network followed the
sweater's advice and put facts first on
russia collusion
and then the hunter scandal what was it
uh
was it last week dana we were we making
fun of the aoc
sweatshirt she was selling that for what
68 bucks this is 380.
yeah i mean and i don't unders did well
look i think it's hard to get dressed
every day to figure out what you're
going to wear so i'm not going to
criticize
but i did do we know did cnn buy that
for her or she buy it herself i don't
know it's a lot of money for a sweater
i think it looks it makes the 68 dollar
sweatshirt look like a bargain
judge cashmere is that usually retail
for about 380.
yeah i imagine it does but so here's the
thing what is the facts first
i mean you know wasn't it zucker telling
everybody on the phone don't do this
don't talk about hunter biden
you know talk about how bad trump is as
if facts first have any meaning to any
of them over there at cnn i mean you
know the whole thing is upside down
geraldo i'm sure you know as well as
anybody like myself no you never want to
criticize what a woman wears
so i'm just not going to say anything
about this you would agree that that's
the smartest route to take right
well i i i will take the chance to say
about cnn
facts first is ridiculous it's untrue
with the exception of john king
he does put facts first but that as a
network they become a propaganda machine
to attack donald trump
for them to say facts first that makes
me want to gag
greg you wear a lot of sweaters uh what
say you
yeah put it up there again uh let me
take a look at this uh just so you know
it's four hundred dollars but a hundred
dollars go to charity so that makes it
okay
right but if you look at this that looks
like how i write a check when i'm drunk
uh just doesn't you know i wouldn't call
it particularly well designed
but it's like 400 bucks but they you
know they say oh we're gonna give 100
bucks to charity
that makes it okay why not just give it
all to charity you selfish people
all right and finally a language
learning app coming up
with a list of the most mispronounced
words of 2020.
some of them are pretty tough and even
yours truly had a little trouble
pronouncing one of them
i have been mispronouncing something i
have been saying
nevada apparently the way to pronounce
the state is nevada
i apologize i will not mis make that
mistake ever again
see dana at least i own up to my
mistakes everybody just glosses over
theirs
well um yes i think that nevada is one
though
jesse you're not alone lots of people
get that one wrong recently
senator kelly lefler has been
her last name has been pronounced across
the media as loffler
but i'm here to tell you it is leffler
right
geraldo what about you nevada is a
spanish word you had it right nevada
means snow
peaks uh snowy mountains uh so you were
you were right from the get-go and
now they're trying to make you be a
gringo pronouncer nevada
that's great to hear heraldo thank you
judge
yeah i got nothing to say
honest that's fine we'll go to greg
that's really not an option
you know uh she's right though this is
this is a
stup stupid it's stupid look hard to
pronounce
words exist because you're not supposed
to say them they're like the weakest
words in the evolutionary
design right you know do you want me to
blow your mind about words
okay this is the most common words are a
and and the and guess what they're also
the shortest words right
because the length of the word is
dictated by its frequency
imagine if our most common words were
long words like the
was like 12 letters in three syllables
we would never be able to communicate
we would actually probably die because
it would take too long
for us to ask for a cheeseburger
see i can't compete with you i don't
know what he said
yeah i'm sorry he just like short words
because he's biased
don't